thank you  because Power Square Bishop is so bad  though oh wow oh my gosh oh you can take  and go Queen B5 check yeah you're right  massive blunder is it huge Amanda and  Vincent has paused Magnus maybe hasn't  realized Bishop takes porn this is why  just knowing the evaluation at one point  in any chess game can be decisive this  is a check and a fork we hadn't spotted  this it's not immediately obvious but if  you get a nudge from the computer like  this with the evaluation  uh you find the winning move simply and  it does exist and it seems like  Vincent's census the fact that he's  paused me it means it's on his radar so  it looks like automatic uh the bishop  has to retreat run away but then black  is fine but Bishop takes Pawn either you  win a pawn two Bishops or you win even  more  with this double attack wow and Magnus  not reacting if he's seen it is it  important that he that he does  Vincent trusts him maybe Vincent was  scared in this type of